hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the first session of
introduction to big data bioinformatics
program
this online program is designed for
everyone including students who don't
have a background in bioinformatics and
biologists to learn about ngs data
analysis processing sections genomics
transcriptomics and biomedical data
science and machine learning
as a result participants will become
proficient in the analysis and
interpretation of various types of omics
data using bioinformatics including
commonly used statistical and machine
learning techniques
my name is sunali khadri and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community managed by pine
biotech
so before we start with the talk i would
want to introduce us we are a u.s based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
omixlogic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omix logic
is an international program that is
running in five different regions with
over 10 000 users around the world and
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
omixlogic programs follow a
project-based learning approach using
research-grade tools to analyze data
from top peer-reviewed journals
omixlogic training has been completed by
participants from
countries in over 300 workshops for six
different specialization tracks
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science or
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis as well
so to begin with today's session let me
quickly guide you through the omics
logic learn courses projects show you
how you have to complete your profile
give an overview of the tools and
resources associated with the program
and discuss the schedule as well i would
also take you through the communication
portals and guides and guide you through
so once you are signed up on the
learn.ormixlogic portal please make sure
that you have a complete profile now by
completing your profile i mean you
should have a profile
if you could make a pause here let's let
some people
make sure that everybody's registered i
don't know where we were running with
this let's uh
let's make sure that everybody signed up
first
so if you
have signed up please put number one or
yes or something like that in chat
if you have not signed up yet this is a
free sign up
so
please let us know once you have
navigated to the link the link is in the
chat
okay so let's wait for a minute for
everyone to quickly sign up
and those who have completed their sign
up they can uh complete their profile
add their profile picture at their uh
bio and also connect their social media
accounts
yes aurora so if you are uh if you have
an account that's nice make sure that
your profile is complete
and uh if you would like to register
after the first session you can
so now sonic if you could go to your own
profile and maybe show how do you get to
the profile how do you complete these
things can you let us know yeah sure
yeah thank you
okay so once you have completed your
signup you need to go to your profile
and make sure that you have an updated
profile picture
also link in your social accounts and
have a brief bio about yourself and make
sure that as a part of the program you
must have the uh introduction to big
data bioinformatics badge on your
profile and you would be able to also
view the program that you have enrolled
for if you have completed your
enrollment for this particular program
and also you would be able to view all
the courses that you are
undergoing or have completed and would
be able to find your certificates in the
certificate section itself under your
profile
now let me know the person if a person
so america doesn't see the badge for
bioinformatics for this program
introduction to bioinformatics
if they don't see a badge then please
let us know so that we can just add you
to the program page now uh
looking the like having the badge is
important on your profile because that
means that you have the access to the
program page now what this program page
is and why is it important let me just
take you through that so this is the
program page for uh the program
introduction to big data bioinformatics
and here on the program page you would
be able to
see all the session details the topic
and the title and all the topics that
are going to be covered in that
particular session and also the schedule
for that and you would be able to look
at the zoom session link as well which
would be along with these sessions
uh as well and once the session is
complete then you will be able to look
at the recordings of that particular
session and once the recording has been
uploaded you are supposed to click on
the complete session icon so that you
complete the sessions and get the
certificate under the profile section
that i mentioned
so this is how you're going to look at
the zoom session link and also complete
the session
and if you have any any doubts we can we
can communicate by the slack channel as
well i'll just take you to the slack
channel uh
in the slides later
also you would be getting 500 points for
completing your course and 100 points
for running a pipeline 100 points for
updating your profile and 10 points for
your group activity
and throughout the course you will be
given directions to access the t bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transcriptomics data and
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipeline and different
stages of analysis could be performed in
different sections of this multi-omics
platform
as i told that we will be communicating
via the slack channel i would be sending
the sessions invite recording after each
session and also the assignment
questions in the slack channel itself
you can also take your doubt and let us
know if you face any technical issue in
the channel itself i've sent this slack
invite to everyone who has enrolled for
the program so please find the
invitation in your mailbox and accept it
and if you have not yet received the
link then please check your spam box or
let me know so that i can send the
invitation again
uh it would be great if nobody you could
just share the link thank you so much
navi has shared the link to the slack
channel and also to the various groups
on whatsapp telegram linkedin you can be
a part of it and also stay updated with
all our upcoming programs and uh also
for your doubts you have the link to the
slack channel
yes oh jesse thank you so much only the
registered participants will be able to
see the batches on their loan profile
and now i would like to pass it on to uh
pine biotech ceo ilya brodsky to take
this session ahead over to julia
thank you
if you could please make me co-host
yes
[Music]
you can discuss that with him in the
chat that's why we have a chat box
can you thank you okay
so welcome everyone to this program and
just to clarify i don't think it was
very clear what sonorico was mentioning
since this is an open session for anyone
to join this is the first session of a
training program that is starting today
on 24th of september and it's going to
last for one month until october 26th
during this program we will cover a
variety of topics in bioinformatics
which will i will briefly introduce but
just before i get into the topics i want
to clarify how these programs work
after you've signed up on this portal
the honors logic learn portal if you are
interested to join this program you'll
have to navigate to this tab called
programs
and in this program tab you search for
introduction
to big data bioinformatics right here
you will find other programs here as
well but this is the program that we're
going to be discussing today
once you are on this page
you can request more information which
will also give you the link to today's
webinar how to join
or you can see the pricing to actually
purchase your access for the whole month
now what is going to be covered in this
program is described right here on the
schedule but a lot of the resources that
we're going to leverage are also
available in an asynchronous format
which means that you can join the
program to participate in live
discussions and hands-on practical
exercises guided by a mentor or you can
gain access to the same exact materials
without this kind of mentorship
and that will be just the basic
subscription that you can get for the
learn moments logic portal
i hope that that is clear to everyone
and if you do have any questions so
manika and others are available in the
chat so you can ask questions
in the meantime i want to introduce you
briefly to some of the topics about
bioinformatics and what will be covered
in this particular
program
and then show you a couple of things
related to what we will have uh
some of the exercises the hands-on
exercises that we will do
so what is bioinformatics
bioinformatics is the intersection of
computational technologies related to
data analysis
and biology so we typically analyze
biological data
but as you have seen the program is
called big data
bioinformatics so why big data
bioinformatics what is the difference
bioinformatics has led to many
discoveries in a variety of different
domains
related to clinical
biotechnology
and other industry applications
and in many cases it has been driven by
our ability to both
generate a lot of data and analyze and
integrate this kind of data
a lot of this has been tremendously
shaped by novel technologies over the
past decade
so the whole field of omics has
developed maybe in the past couple of
decades
but it has accelerated its development
over the past decade and so as a result
of having this kind of data we are
seeing a lot of ability to find novel
diagnostic
methods
and identify novel therapeutics and so a
lot of what we're going to be talking
about in this program is going to be
related to the application of
bioinformatics in the biomedical domain
and because of the this new type of data
we're talking about
ability to sequence tumors
ability to identify novel
variation in pathogen genomes we're
talking about ability to analyze data
from patients and identify patterns that
are unique at the whole system level or
at individual cell level
and so to understand all of these
different topics we've designed this
program that will focus on a variety of
different types of omics data
that you can actually learn how to
analyze throughout this program
so here i have a slide that talks a
little bit about several different types
of omics data
this includes
phenomics a collection of phenotypic
data
genomic data
genomic variation like single nucleotide
variations copy number variations
that is in the genome in the dna
epigenomic data or data that describes
epigenetic mechanisms of regulation of
gene expression
actual gene expression data where we
analyze levels of transcript and gene
expression in a
tissue or a cell or the full organism
and after this we have proteomics and
metabolomic so several different types
of omics data
this data is widely available so many
different labs around the world
with experts generate data sets
following their experiments and we have
the benefit of having free access to a
lot of this data with a description of
what the data is generated by which
mechanism
to investigate a particular question or
around a particular design of a topic or
a project and so a lot of what we're
going to be doing in this particular
program is we're going to be leveraging
these public domain data sets
around topics like oncology neuroscience
and infectious diseases to understand
how this data can answer biological
questions and what are some of the key
terms and techniques you need to
understand to be able to analyze this
data properly
so the introduction to bioinformatics
program
will give you a sense of novel
technologies
emerging technologies like next
generation sequencing and the way that
they are continuing to develop
it will give you an understanding of
genomic data analysis so what are dna
variants and mutations and how to
analyze genomic data to find specific
types of variation at the dna level
introduction to transcriptomic data
analysis where we will identify gene and
isoform expression quantification and
analysis we'll also talk a little bit
about statistical methods of analysis as
well as machine learning so what do you
need to know to read papers and maybe
try some of these methods on your own
you will be introduced to scripting in
python in r so that you understand at
least how to get started and i will show
you today a couple of examples for that
and then you will be left with
a selection of projects that come from
curated data sets that were extracted
from peer-reviewed publications and
public domain repositories so you can
actually try to replicate somebody
else's analysis and see how that
analysis can inform
different types of insights
about different domains like oncology
and others
so as i mentioned
a lot of what we're going to be doing is
going to be found as an asynchronous
version of what we will cover in live
sections
uh on this portal
learnomicslogic.com so i want to briefly
show you how to find the associated
asynchronous resources so that you can
get started right away
the resources could be found in several
different ways so you have a search bar
where you can search for any topic you
have tags right here
and you also have specialized
collections and the collections are
organized right here and what we'll get
what we will be taking a look at today
is a collection called getting started
so let me show you how to find this
information
let's go to this link called courses and
please let me know when you are there
so you can put number one
or yes
in the chat thank you
okay so once you are here you will find
that you have your profile and under
your profile you can see a few stats
about your progress and activity
for example my total achievements how
many courses i completed how many
lessons i completed lesson steps and
code blocks and i will show you today
where to find all of these different
elements
here you have a section that is based on
popularity so
as you complete your profile as you
develop your profile you complete
different topics and different lessons
the system will learn from your activity
and will start recommending most popular
courses for people that have a similar
profile to you
then down here you will find
two different kinds of courses some of
them will start as a course so for
example you'll see course these are
technical tutorials and theoretical
tutorials to explain a particular
topic in general
and then you can also search for project
so these are project examples as i
mentioned these are curated data sets
extracted from
publications and turned into an
explanation and illustration of a
particular bioinformatics analysis
method in the context of that particular
research project
here you have tags for example if i
cancel project i can look for projects
or courses right here i can also look
for data science courses or i can look
for
genomics courses and projects etc so
this is just a way to navigate some of
the content right here
down here below you will find different
collections and so the collection we
want to look at is this collection
called getting started so if you click
on getting started
i can actually share this link right
here so this is the link that we want to
take a look at today just so that you
understand what are the different things
that are going to be included
in
this program and kind of where you can
get started for this program
so as you can see
there is course one introduction to
bioinformatics
which is a course that talks about the
applications of bioinformatics in
healthcare pharmaceutical biotechnology
agriculture and other domains
another course that you can find here is
a course called bytes and molecules
this course provides you with an
overview of terminology and different
elements that you have to know about to
be able to start using bioinformatics so
we'll start from the very beginning what
is dna what are nucleotides how does
they organized into chromosomes and how
do you analyze genomic data what is this
genomic data so it's a course for
beginners you can see at the bottom of
each course there's a difficulty score
and so all of these courses are going to
be very low on the difficulty score so
for those of you that are just getting
started these are some of the things
that you can start with
now some of these courses are also going
to introduce you to coding right so we
talked a little bit about coding so i
want to just show you a brief
illustration of what that means
you will see here that there are just
introductory things that you have to
know
to be able to get started for example
how to load data how to visualize how to
read dna sequences and how to
convert dna to rna so just kind of
getting started right
the same type of material is available
for python as well
but a lot of what we're going to be
doing will require some much more
advanced methods of analysis
and so for those advanced methods of
analysis we're actually going to rely on
the t-bioinfo platform
so once you have registered on the
portal and if you have completed your
registration for the program yesterday
you should already be able to use your
credentials to log in on the server
so the
the
le the time that it takes for the
password to be generated on the platform
is about 24 hours so if you have just
signed up today you probably still don't
have access to the platform but if you
signed up over the past week you should
be able to use the same credentials that
you use on the omixlogic portal here on
this platform
so
please go to this link i shared the link
in chat and i will show you a few
different sections that we're going to
review in this program and please let me
know once you're here
all right thank you
okay so let's take a look at some of the
different sections that we're going to
be reviewing so a lot of what we're
going to be talking about is big data a
lot of the big data comes from next
generation sequencing
and so right here this section
refers to next generation sequencing
applications there are different types
of applications
related to the different types of omics
data so here we have transcriptomic data
genomic data we also have non-coding dna
and rna as well as metagenomic data
right here so several different types of
data and these are what is called
processing
sections so let's take a look at this
first section to understand what that
means
so this first section is called rna-seq
rna-seq refers to processing
next-generation sequencing
transcriptomic data
so if we go into this drop-down
we will see several demo pipelines
these demo pipelines will really
illustrate how this platform works and
how we will leverage it throughout this
program
so if you go to this first demo rna seek
cell line project
click on it you should be able to see
what i am seeing on my screen now
obviously you have to be signed in
before you get here if you don't have a
sign in but you've registered for the
program you just have to wait uh a
little bit longer for that to be
uh
when will t-bio docking be activated
zara is asking so there already is a
docker system behind the t-bio info you
can run it on google cloud
uh but that requires a research license
okay so for
please let me know if you see what i see
on my screen
all right thank you
all right
oh
okay great so so what what is this
interface this interface
hides the complexity of a typical step
for loading processing and running
different kinds of algorithms behind a
user user-friendly interface
the user-friendly interface
puts
any script into a button and some of
these buttons will have some settings
so if you click on start you'll see here
how we use this platform for education
one of the major challenges in learning
next generation sequencing data analysis
is understanding the logic behind
what step do i need to take to get my
data into a certain format that i needed
to be in
and in the rna-seq pipeline there are
several different steps that we have to
understand logically
the first one is pre-processing or how
to clean up the raw data before we start
the analysis
the second one is mapping or how do we
connect the randomly generated reads to
the proper position on the genome
and the final step is quantification so
how do we actually count how many reads
fell onto a particular gene
as you will learn throughout this
program this is not a
simple process to understand and we'll
go into great detail to explain what are
the reads what are we trimming how do we
map them what are the different
strategies for mapping and how to
quantify and analyze the resulting gene
expression table
if you scroll down you will see here an
example pipeline
so let's try to recreate this pipeline
together and see what will be the output
so as you can see the first is start we
already selected that
then we go to trim-o-matic from
trim-o-matic we go to pcr clean then we
go to a button called bow tie 2t
and finally rsem expression table and so
after we go through these steps we
connect it to the end to run the
pipeline
so this pipeline is as you can see color
coded it separates these different steps
into colors
blue
is for what do you think the blue means
we just looked at it but i'm just
checking to see if you remember
pre-processing excellent so
what do you think pre-processing means
good afternoon
cleaning up the data exactly so we have
raw data we need to clean it up and so
the way we clean it up as we will see
is trimming the reeds and eliminating
some extra reads
then we go to red what do you think red
means
mapping excellent
so here we have mapping as you can see
it says right here mapping on
transcripts right so we need to remember
what are we actually mapping to and
we'll talk about this in greater detail
in a little bit
and then here we have green
it says here expression levels but it's
really quantification how do we count
whatever we have
mapped onto a particular region so let's
click on ok
and now as you can see several of these
buttons are highlighted and some of them
are not highlighted
so based on what you remember
try to replicate the same
pipeline that we just saw on the screen
and once you're done once you have
clicked on end
let me know
i'll give it
30 seconds
all right did anyone complete the
pipeline
excellent
george george
anyone else
okay let's try to do this together
so we go from start to pre-processing
trimmimatic
what does trimomatic do it trims the
reeds as you can see there's a good
portion of the reed and a bad portion of
the reed so we trim it
okay yes
after traumatic pcr clean
and you can see that it's the only
option available so what are we cleaning
here
here we are cleaning the bridge pcr
amplification
which means that we are reducing some of
the duplicate reads that
have a bias just because pcr has a bias
towards certain sequences
the only option that well the only two
options that we have are two of them
mapping algorithms high sat2 and both
i2t
what is the difference
as you can see hysat2
combines several different steps
mapping on genome exon detection and
mapping on junctions
the bowtie 2t is a more simple version
that just maps it on transcripts
to understand what the difference is we
have certain coursework that you can
complete if you're not familiar with the
difference between transcripts or
mapping on genome but for now let's just
click on bowtie2t
and this algorithm is an algorithm that
is described in this publication so if
you want to learn more about this
publication you can click on this and
read more about it
after we have mapped on transcripts
we are using rsem
or rna-seq using expectation
maximization
to quantify the level of gene expression
and so as a result from raw reads or
fast q files we will end up with a gene
expression table so after you click here
you click on ok and the only step left
is end
once you click on edge you should see
the screen that i see
so again i'll just wait a little bit
please let me know when you have gotten
to the same result
so that we can move on
i want to move on together make sure
that everybody's following along all
right thank you eman
anyone else
if you're here you can click on this
right here and see several data sets
that you can download
so please let me know once you're here
yes i will get to that in a second in
mind i will show you
what i am describing today is just one
of the exercises that we will be doing
later on in the program in greater
detail but i also will show you an
asynchronous version of this tutorial so
that you can follow along and learn
about all the different options
okay so if you're here you will see
several different outputs cell lines
clinical subtypes
cell lines expression data normalized
and annotated
exon expression cell lines expression
genes cell lines and expression
cell line so really several different
outputs are provided to us from a single
pipeline
and so what we want to take a look at is
at cell lines expression data normalized
and annotated so please click on this
file and you will see that it will be
downloaded onto your computer
so why and
what was the input data great question
so i will explain in a second and i will
actually show you how to find all of
this information in the asynchronous
tutorial
so i'm just going to open this table in
excel to see what is in the data and the
reason we're looking at it is because we
want to understand what is the meaning
of big data bioinformatics how did omics
data really change the way that we have
to handle and process data from
traditional bioinformatics
so
let me know once you've gotten this
opened or if you're following along just
watching me
you will see here that i have
genes in this column id
and right here i have names of cell
lines these are different types of
breast cancer cell lines
so if you count the total number of
genes you will see that there's close to
7 000 genes
and
if you go to the top and scroll to the
end you will see that there's actually
about
50 different cell lines right here
so what is the purpose of rna-seq
rna-seq helps us understand the levels
of gene expression
so that we can find meaningful patterns
in this data
so if we take a look at one gene for
example the first one
and we can create here a bar plot just
to see what this data looks like
we will see that this particular gene
has a certain profile
sometimes it is up regulated sometimes
it is down regulated and since we have
so many different sections down at the
bottom the question becomes well which
gene
or which collection of genes from this
whole data set could actually mean
something of interest to somebody who is
exploring
cancer and specifically different types
of breast cancer
and that is the challenge because as you
can see if i have to manually go through
each individual gene
and i have to look at the profile to
determine what could this mean
it becomes a tedious and very
complicated task because i have over
7000 genes
now many genes are going to be
informative
and many genes are going to be
non-informative but also i have over 70
different samples and in many projects
that you will take a look at there's
actually thousands or hundreds of
samples and so the task as you can see
for a manual analysis becomes too
complicated too complex and so i have to
rely on computational technologies to
really make sense of what is going on
so now let me show you
this is a snapshot of something that you
can learn
in this program but also something that
you can learn on your own
based on your interest if your interest
is transcriptomics you can just go into
the courses tab right here and search
for
transcriptomics
and you will see here a full course
that explains
how
rna
helps us investigate protein expression
and correlate that with phenotype
what are the different types of
techniques to quantify mrna
how
rna-seq and next-generation sequencing
is generating this kind of data so iman
you were asking where's the input data
so that will explain to you what the
input data looks like
then it will talk about the steps that
we took and what are the actual inputs
and outputs for every step every button
that we took has an input has an output
then you will learn about how to build
several different pipelines just like
what we did today
then you will see how the data is
prepared for downstream analysis
how to explore this complex data set
using the platform so again no coding
involved
how to perform statistical tests and
here you have a button to load more
and you will see that this will include
other types of analysis including
downstream analysis so annotation of
genes and pathway analysis what you
would typically see
in analysis of differential gene
expression
advanced statistical techniques like
factor regression analysis
and all the way to supervised and
unsupervised machine learning and after
that you can try to explore some of the
same methods in python and in r
okay but this is too much
for just this one month okay this one
month subscription actually gives you
access to all the courses but let me
show you which courses are we actually
going to complete during this one month
okay so again if we go back to courses
you can go to
getting started this is the collection
to getting started
and here you can see some of the
asynchronous courses that you will be
able to complete
during this one month you have access to
more but during this one month we expect
to complete all of these
now in addition to this if you go back
to the program and remember the name of
this program is introduction
to big data
bioinformatics right here introduction
to big data bioinformatics
if you've already registered for the
program
you will see that today we are doing
this introduction to big data in biology
so you already saw
the program tools and resources
the ones that have been registered have
been added already to the slack channel
and maybe you can say hello on the slack
channel so we can all connect
you've seen the different tools and
resources for this program
including the courses projects and how
to get to your profile
and you've seen an overview of the tbio
info analytical platform
and so before we turn to our q a session
i want to briefly
summarize what are the different topics
you will see
and how they apply
to a variety of sections
that we have covered on this portal
the onyx logic idea is to provide you
with a logical overview of different
types of analysis techniques
to help you identify how these
techniques could be applied in these
fields right here oncology
infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture so after
you learn about some of these basic
methods and the logical analysis of this
data you can choose would you like to
apply it to oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience or agriculture
and
once you've understood what the research
question is in one of those domains
then hopefully you'll be able to link
the research question to some of the
technical steps that you need to take to
analyze data and find answers
and so to briefly
illustrate how this will work i want to
invite dr harpreet kaur
who is going to be your mentor and her
expertise is in cancer genomics
where she has published numerous
publications and has a lot of expertise
analyzing such data so dr humphrey over
two
thank you
let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
in my current role i am curriculum
developer and research consultant and i
am
the mentor in i'm one of the mentor in
this program
so today we are going to learn a bit
about big data and then in the next
session onward then we are going to
learn what are the different omics
uh mix types of the big data
okay so let me first
show you like what are the major
characteristics of a data that makes a
data as a big data
so there are some meso 5b that can
define or make a data to a big data
the first one is volume that is amount
of the data
is huge for example we know that uh
ngsrn is c theta which is
information about thousands of the genes
for or millions of s and p so eventually
overall they conclude or contribute to
the volume
next is variety
so usually or data is unstructured and
can be assembled in many different ways
often a time the same phenomena can be
described many different ways depending
upon the type of the sequencer machine
or depending upon the preparation
technique or handling in a particular
lab
so then the
next is
the value that is the information we get
out of the data is dependent upon many
factors or respects
that include data noise technical uh
error rate and complete eventually the
completeness of information is provided
by various factors
then there is
bearish t that is
many a time some samples can have a low
coverage
why other have high coverage
but not the full sequences others might
be generated by
old machine or may be generated by new
machine
so
including all the data together complete
the picture about a particular data
then is values t
so this is another important aspect
because as we know that
with the time number of
techniques are also changing for example
single sequencing replaced by short
consequences
sequencing
eventually no a d single cell sequencing
so as the new data is getting added
and
eventually
the this data is continuously growing
before even about understanding about
the already existing information
so all these factors eventually
contribute
for a make a data algebraic data
now let's look at the history of the
genomics data
it's been like 70 years since the
structure in the function of dnu was
discovered
angels immersed with the sequencing of
the first human genome project
and around the year 2015 thousand
genomes
project brought a significant number of
the whole genome sequence to the
research community so by the year 2018
there are like 1 million whole genomes
were sequenced
so today there is ever increasing number
of the data sets available that help
researcher to understand about cellular
and biological processes
eventually this con data is continuously
growing
at is at an exponential rate
as we already learned about they are the
different types of the omics depending
upon the biomolecules that it include
for example phenomics then you deal with
phenotype genomics which deals with the
mutations of the new uh mutations that
are snp or epigenetics which deals with
the methylation data transcriptomics
which deals with the rna transcripts
now many of us must earn many of you are
here must be the biologists
and mostly
biologists were trained in the basic
biological processes and then specialize
in certain area where we gain both
knowledge and the experience from the
experimental data
many of the examples that we learn from
and the information they accumulated
came from carefully designed experiments
where certain assumptions were tested
so the general data from these
experiments confirmed some of the
assumptions and those were recorded as
proven hypothesis
so all the biologists submit their data
to different public repositories
for example ncvi particularly
gene expression omnibus one of them is a
repository where you can find process
data
so that this data is continuously
growing
uh
almost at exponential rate
so the
growth in high throughput sequencing of
the cancer genome and the transcriptome
has produced a big data problem
that precludes many cancer biologists
and oncologists from gleaning knowledge
from these data regarding the nature of
malignant processes as well as the
relationship between
tumor
genomic profiles and the treatment
response
so that's why it is important to learn
about
what are these different data types and
how efficiently we can process and
analyze and that's most of genomics and
transcriptomics data that we are going
to learn in our upcoming session how we
can process that data and eventually how
we can analyze
now there are important repositories
from where you can find
uh these different omics data types for
example one of them is a repository like
geo where you can find already processed
data
then if you are interested in raw
sequencing data then
there is an important repository that is
sequence reader skype that is
sra which maintains
raw sequencing data
then there is like bio project where you
can
find different research projects related
all which are already completed by
different researchers
so besides there are other specific
repositories
like array express gdc data portal
cosmic
and then human protein address where you
can find
data [ __ ] uh related to the oncology
and beside that you can also find
various repositories related to the
viruses now depending upon your research
interest you can obtain data from these
repositories
so this is a one of the dedicated
repositories
ncbi virus which maintains
metadata
and
sequence data for various types of
viruses
so if you have any question regarding
that please feel free to post your query
in the chat box and before we further
proceed
now let's first understand
what what is the
hypothesis approach particularly from
the biologist's perspective
so usually for a biologist
research depend upon the observation
observation that give rise to a question
that can be definitely answered using
data generated in an experiment
and this hypothesis
further can be confirmed depending upon
the experiment design or can be rejected
depending upon the result
now hypothesis eventually depends upon
or accepted or rejected based on what
are the analysis results that you have
obtained
but the collection of the results are
the actual knowledge
so our big data
is changing the way we view the results
or we analyze these results
so results are often at times
the data itself particularly when you're
dealing with
when you are dealing with a
bioinformatics
so then what is the data driven or a
bioinformatics approach
okay so is it some i'm not clearly
audible
so narika can you let me know i'm not
audible
uh no mom you're audible to us we can
hear you clearly
okay thank you
okay so the apart from the biologist
perspective research now what is the big
data
approach big data right approach or data
driven research approach let's
understand what are the important aspect
here
so for example a big data approach or
data-driven approach is more dependent
on the data itself rather than the
hypothesis
so here for example if a disease or rate
could be forecasted like baby or weather
so then communities could set up the
protective measure to control their
impact
so their goal is to develop a better
understanding how are dissipated
eventually
how we are able to predict disease
outbreak
as we know that researchers are
generating large volumes of biological
data which have changed the way the
biomedical research is done
an important respect of the big data
analysis is to is the ability to
identify trends in the omics data itself
without any experimental or clinical
mechanistic
so typically this approach is known as
data-driven approach
so next of course by harnessing machine
learning tools one can discover the
relationship or trends in the data that
are not obvious enabling researcher to
ask specific question on the basis of
computer identified trends
now let's understand how we can proceed
for data driven research
so typically this researcher poll
approach has made the six step for
example first of all we
identify our research question or maybe
we also try to identify alternative to
our perception
next we go for the literature review
where we search who has already invested
invest
invest investigated this problem before
us
but approach has been taken in the past
to solve this particular research
question
subsequently we design our prediction
model or we formulate a hypothesis
how might specific variable influence
the result of chosen predictive model
so once we done with these steps then we
proceed to gather the data
collect information about the variable
particularly based on
our hypothesis that now we are designing
eventually we had it towards a data
analysis where we can apply various
statistical models to evaluate the
correctness of approach and then we
repeat this procedure until we finally
identify the best method
eventually you can
eventually be a
compiler or result into a story
now let's understand
how a big data helping clinicians and
researchers in precision medicine
let's take a simple example
for example we have a patient and it
gives a tumor sample to allow which
completes its genetic uh genetic
genomics or protein analysis and then
send the data to a bioinformatician
so finally a bind for meditation analyze
the sample for omics data types may be
it is or
she is or a one permutation analyzing
mutation data maybe a gene
genomics data that or a transcriptomic
data or a protein data
so accordingly they find some important
genes or a protein or maybe of
snp features that are significant for a
particular tumor condition or a
therapeutic condition
so from the results based on the omics
data analysis a drug therapy can be
recommended that closely align with the
patient's molecular profile
this would include both the baby fda
approved trust or maybe unapproved drugs
then you will see the or
researcher analyze the effects and those
genes or signatures which assessing the
drug effect are known as predictive
biomarkers so based on the analysis
result one can identify important
diagnostic prognostic and predictive
biomarkers
eventually the physician as well as the
patients are provided with additional
evidence including what are the adverse
reactions
failure rates and other treatment
tradeoff they should consider when they
making final decision
at the beginning or during the course of
a treatment
so the patient and physician in turn
provide information to strengthen
uh database for the future uh future
basic uh drug designing
so during this program you are going to
we are going to explore different
projects
so based on the transcriptomics genomics
or metagenomics data
now let let's take one example of one of
the project that is pdx project that we
are going to use particularly for
transcriptomics data analysis
so this is one of the publication
from which we have taken the data
so
in the year 2016 there was a research
article published in the ongo target
where broadside at all have explored
whole transcriptome profiling of a
patient right genograph or pdx model
as a tool to identify both tumor and
stromal specific biomarkers
so the authors investigated rna-seq as a
hypothesis free tool to generate
independent tumor and stromal biomarkers
and explore tumor stroma interactions by
exploiting human urine department
specialty of the pdx model
so in this study authors have explored
nearly 79 pdx models and they determine
that most roma can be separated into
displaced clusters and each cluster
is correspond to a specific normal uh
cell type
so in our program we will try to perform
various ngs data analysis using these
pdx models now let's also understand
what are the pdx models
so pdx models are generated when a fresh
tumor uh stress tumor tissue obtained
directly from the patients and then it
implanted subcutaneously or
orthotopically into immune deficient
mice
so as such these pdx models maintain
principal histological clinical and
molecule characteristics of the original
human tumors
while it remains biologically stable
so since these pdx models are more
closely resemble and recalculate
tumor growth in humans than standard in
vitro cell lines so the that's why these
pdx models are nowadays more preferred
model for pre-clinical drug development
studies
so here we are going to uh explore
particularly pdx project for breast
cancer so here we have two breast cancer
subtypes that is er positive and triple
negative now what is er positive and
triple negative
so estrogen receptor positive breast
cancer is identified by the presence of
estrogen receptor on a cell membrane
while triple negative breast cancer
lacks three important
membrane receptors on its membrane so
this is just one difference that makes
your uh ear positive breast cancer as
more treatable bile triple negative is
more aggressive subtype of the
breast breast cancer
now let me show you how you can learn at
least to get an overview about uh
precision medicine so let me take you to
some of the courses
that you can explore
so just give me a second and let me know
how many of you have already account on
learning
so how many of you have account on learn
platform
navia lilliana okay great
so here are some of the courses that you
must go through to just understand the
basic understanding about these genomics
recession medicine or the application of
the bioinformatics
so here's the first course as elia also
shown you that is bytes and molecules
so this is the one of the force where
you will get an overview about
different
types of terms if you are uh very much
new to the balusi so you will get the
basic thermology in terms of these
dna structure protein structure
genomics then transcriptomics
so these are the primary courses so then
another important course specifically
what are the different applications of
the
bioinformatics so here is another
important course
that is introduction to the
bioinformatics
particularly that is course number one
so this is the course where you will
learn the different applications of
bioinformatics in diverse trades
including healthcare as well as
agriculture so this is the first course
that you must complete these are the two
courses
that i would recommend you
now let me also show you how you can get
familiar if you are interested to learn
programming skills so for example here
in the course number eight in bytes and
molecules you will find the simplest
simple course that is introduction to
the bioinformatics language so here we
are introducing r
so here you will learn how you can
install r on your system
and next how you can
write or read a file in r so here under
the
getting started with r so you will learn
for example this is the simple code
block
and here this
code block is given and then each step
what uh each syntax is defined below for
example what is the meaning of free
table what we are doing with this so
it will help you to understand what is
why we are doing header equal to true
separator what you understand by
separator row name so then how you can
visualize your data
now let me also show you with an
exercise so you are also learn about
what are the what is the metric or data
frame in our in simplest way so for
example in the metrics so usually when
you have one type of data whether it is
numeric or whether you have numeric as
well as a character so
in case of the data frame then you are
dealing with different types of
data type that is numeric as well as
non-numeric data so then you will learn
how you can
read different types of files so here in
the each course you will learn how you
can check the dimensions of your data so
after the learning so then how you can
visualize your data in the next step you
will learn how you can actually execute
your code
so here
some syntax is missing so you need to
complete for example here is the
simplest
code where you just need to understand
like what is this
table so let me just show you for
example we have this file so let me copy
this
now for example how i can read this data
but before that i should visualize what
kind of data i have so
if you just copy the link in the browser
in any other tab you will see like here
you have this id so you have these
columns
in the first column you have gs then you
have samples so now how we can read this
kind of data how these columns are
separated from each other whether they
are separated by a comma whether they
are separated by semicolon or a tab so
how i can read this kind of data
so what i can do first let's create a
simple object theta you can write it as
anything
so as r is an object-oriented language
so we are creating an object data so
then we are assigning our
uh
our data into this object so how i can
read simple table uh simple gene
expression table or simple file in r so
there is simple comma a syntax that is
the dot table
so then here we need to provide a path
of our file if you are doing it on your
r studio then you can provide the
directory directory folder name
here we have url so we need to provide
the url next i need to define
whether my file has
header or not
so if i am looking at this file
so here i have header i have row name
so i need to define header equal to true
then
whether there we have row name
equal to one in the first row we have
row name then how the columns in this
file are separated from each other so
there is one simple function with the
sap
separator so here we need to provide
what kind of separator in our data
for example here we have tab separator
now how we can check the dimension so as
here it is given you need to check the
dimensions of data so here the simple
command that is them
we can check the dimensions of data
so i missed actually d so that is why
it's showing the error if you look at
here you will find
in the console you will find errors so
it automatically could not find function
3 because i've missed d
so no i can
i corrected that now i can so you can
see success running code and answer is
correct so this is how we can do if you
are don't know how to install or on your
system so you can directly do this in
simply this learn platform here we
giving you that option as well similarly
you can visualize for example head
command with the head command you can
visualize top rows
so
we can visualize
now i can comment and of course in any
programming language so this
hash sign is for the comment so that is
just a comment it is not a command so
now we can
although it will show
answer is incorrect why because actually
when i have this we have defined these
answers
so we have not
especially we are just checking the
dimensions so that is why otherwise you
can
simply if your code is running
successfully it means your code is
running here so you can learn like how
you can read or you can draw simple box
plot in of your data for example here
once we read the data we can summarize
our data in the form of box plot so if i
run this command you will see
here i got simple box plot
so then you will learn how to add color
title to the box plot so here you can
learn or explore these kind of
uh simplest code first here if you are
new to
r otherwise there are many uh main
courses like data science in our or data
science in python if you want to explore
much more
so this is how you can run any code or
on learn platform if you have any
question please feel free to
post your query on the chat box
so in the next so here 2d the whatever
main assignments that i am giving you
please go to go through this particular
lesson that is introduction to the
bioinformatics
because it will give you like what are
the different applications of the
bioinformatics and go through the whites
and molecules because they are very
introductory lessons you will learn
about
simplest terms in the biology as well as
the bioinformatics
so those are the two assignments and on
the monday we are going to learn about
genomics data analysis and what are the
different file formats and that we are
going to cover in our next session
so thank you if you have a questions
feel free to post your query in chat box
and i will address meanwhile i am
passing uh handing over this session
back to sunalika so that she if you get
to register so you she will explain
registration process
so over to you youtube
thank you so much ma'am so first of all
i'll just uh go through the registration
process and then i have to answer few of
the queries that the participants had so
the first thing is that uh as india has
already told that if you are yet to
register yourself so the first session
was uh free for everyone just because
uh
the interested parents had to have an
insight so what all would be covered
so here is the link to the
program page you can register yourself
with any of the level that you would
like to enroll in here on the program
page itself
so now there are three levels beginner
intermediate and advanced and these
levels have different sorts of
facilities you can say that you would be
provided with and it depends on you
which level you want to enroll for
now the second thing is that uh on the
omnilogic learn portal
you have two parts the first part is the
courses tab and the second part is the
program stack
and those people who just want to go
through the asynchronous course material
at their own pace and get an
understanding of various sorts of fields
which are mentioned here on omix and
data science and also we have uh sample
projects which you can go through and
learn from as in few of them are
mentioned here as well so you just have
to click on courses let's say you will
get you will get a list of courses that
you can go through
and if you want to have a look on the
projects then just pick the project and
go through the projects very simple very
easy now that is the way uh you can get
the access to the courses and that is
for a basic subscription of dollar tech
and
those who are enrolled
is someone saying something
so if you have any doubt please uh post
in the chat box
uh can i continue so i was saying that
for the courses are the basic
subscription module is dollar ten and
those who have taken the basic
subscription module for dollar ten
they uh will just have the access to the
courses and not to the programs now
introduction to big data bioinformatics
is a program in which we are going to
have online sessions and
mentor guidance one on one mentor
guidance and we will be also providing
with various course materials and these
programs they're like specialized
programs for the fields that we have
talked about
so uh and also i had a question by sri
hari
uh sri hari can you please ask a
question once again i've lost a question
uh in the chat box on top you can unmute
yourself and ask
hello everyone can you tell me about uh
how to start with the courses is it
how to start with the courses right so
the first thing that you have to begin
with is the introduction to uh
bioinformatics course that is mentioned
in the courses tab and that dr harpreet
took you through as well and also as bam
has given you an assignment that you
have to go through the course and uh now
there are two type of bio information
those who are entrusted to learn coding
and those who are not right so you are
one of them who wants to learn about r
and python and get into data science so
to begin with you have to start with
getting started with our and python
courses
i'm so sorry i had a background
disturbance could not hear you please
repeat
can you tell me when the tbio info
portal access can be obtained
yes so you all will get your credentials
for the server just after this session
i'll be sharing your credentials with
you and these credentials would be
active for one month for the uh course
duration
right and you can uh navigate through
the portal and browse different sorts of
courses that you can begin with and then
uh get along and you will be given
guidance and notes and course materials
and assignments as well along with the
program and you can take your doubts in
the next session so you go through the
material that we discussed today and
then you uh take your doubts at the next
session and make sure that you all are
there on the uh
like um join the slack channel
and also uh you can find the recording
of this particular session on the
program page and upload that and you'll
be able to see that and also i'll share
the recording by a mail and the slack
channel
yeah
thank you
great
i imando access to the
server is for a month and also those who
have taken then now there are many
people here who have taken the basic
membership of dollar 10 they will have
the access to the servers example
pipelines only but those who are a part
of the program that is the introduction
to big data bioinfo program they will
have the access the educational license
to the server and uh the other various
pipelines would be unlocked for them and
they can practice on that but those who
are apart just with the basic
subscription they'll just have the
access to the demo pipelines and not to
the other pipelines
will i have access to precision medicine
courses
uh precision medicine uh program is
already done actually melinda you were
enrolled in one of the precision
medicine sessions right so yes
definitely actually i'll share the
recordings with you because you were
already a part of the
program and did you uh download your
certificate if not then please let me
know so that i can provide you with a
certificate as well and one thing is
that i told you that you all have to
click on complete session icon after
watching the recording it's uh just
because of that you can get your
certificate in the programs uh in the in
your profile
yes sima i'll share the slack channel
link with all the customers
yes sure melinda you can uh chat with me
separately as well i'll just share my
skype profile idea and i'm also
available on slack you can just drop a
message on slack and take your doubts
okay so if you have any other downs you
can mail me on marketing
at the rate fine dot bio
and i'll be happy to help you all thank
you all for joining the session today it
was really very nice to meet you all
uh yes we do interact um so these
sessions they are not like we just
as in the uh
speaker comes and give lectures and go
no we we definitely interact and we take
doubts and we uh ask participants if
they have any doubts or they're stuck
somewhere and also take their insights
on what they feel about the topic
melinda you can connect with me over
skype or slack i'll share my
profile id with you over your main
address i have your mail address and
also please make sure that our mail
address marketing address pine is added
to your address book because we have
been getting responses from people that
are males are uh
going in their spam box because we
interact with a lot of people so the
spam trigger gets
active
the timing would be this only shri hari
7 pm ist 8 30 am cst
uh yes imam the dollar 10 that you paid
yesterday was a basic subscription
membership for the courses to enroll for
the program we have three very uh three
different levels beginner intermediate
advanced which are for 45 60
45 60 and 75
and we have this basic fee structure
just to sustain the program
uh the basic fee structure is actually
for the lies the license that you're
going to get on the server
because you would be having five
terabyte of space
allocated to uh each one of the users
for your usage and your uploading data
and working on it that's where we have a
particular fee
great
okay then i think
doubts are cleared but if not you
anytime have the option to mail me and
i'll be happy to respond thank you
everyone for joining and thank you dr
harpreet for giving us such an
insightful session today on introduction
to big data bioinformatics and we would
be now meeting um for the next session
where we are going to talk about
genomics
uh so iman the research fellowship
program is about carrying out an
independent research project under
mentor guidance so being a part of the
research fellowship program is a
different sort of thing where you get
the access to the portals courses
specifically the courses and the sample
projects for whatever time period you
enroll be it three months be it six
months and then you carry out your
research project under mental guidance
that is you begin with completing the
course material first and then you fill
in the research proposal form your form
gets approved and
then obviously our mentors are going to
help you modify your research question
if required and then you start working
on your research project under mental
guidance you will get to know from a
mentor from where you have to look for
the date for the data set and then what
are the various steps
you have to apply on your data set to
prepare your data and then how you have
to work on it how you analyze your
results interpreter results in that
matter and then going ahead with
publishing your work in any of the
reputed journals that is the process of
a research fellowship
uh sure okay thank you so much everyone
for joining have a great day